comenzó en la última semana de
septiembre los sindicatos de total
energis llamaron a la huelga amenazando
con bloquear el suministro de
combustible en Francia también lo
hicieron en eso Epson móvil los
trabajadores de las refinerías
demandaban obtener aumentos salariales
para compensar la inflación que
atraviesa el país poco tiempo después
las consecuencias ya se veían en varias
partes del territorio francés largas
filas de automóviles esperaban para
poder conseguir combustible el 7 de
octubre la ministra de transición
energética aseguraba que se trataba de
un problema logístico
este movimiento social dificulta
transportar carburante a un determinado
número de estaciones de servicio este
movimiento solo afecta a un pequeño
número de estaciones de servicio
por su parte el presidente Manuel hacía
un llamado a mantener la calma
sin embargo el descontento en la
refinerías seguían aumento por la
respuesta el gobierno hoy no tenemos
ninguna propuesta concreta sobre la mesa
lo han visto para los huelguistas esto
es inaceptable
reaccionaba el gobierno está haciendo su
parte presionando para que las
negociaciones concluyan lo antes posible
bloquear no es la forma de negociar el
gobierno lanzó una orden para obligar a
los trabajadores esenciales a
desbloquear la refinerías del país lo
que causó el descontento de algunos
sindicalistas pero el martes de la
semana pasada dos refinerías del grupo
eso es un móvil en Francia levantaron la
huelga gracias a un acuerdo salarial y
el viernes total energis y los
sindicatos que representan a la mayoría
de sus trabajadores llegaron a un
acuerdo que contemplaba un aumento del
7% en los salarios a pesar de ello la
huelga continuó la cgt busca un
incremento del 10%